hello and welcome to simplified unit
testing with the EF core in-memory
provider
I'm Jason Taylor and I'm a solution
architect for SSW you can find me on
Twitter Jason G tau or on my blog
codeine flow net I've been developing
software now for about 17 years and I
found that the most important principle
is kiss or keep it simple stupid and
this principle states that systems
should be made as simple as possible but
no simpler and today I'm going to show
you the simplest approach that I've
found to unit testing applications that
depend on energy framework or so if
divided this talk into four sections
we're going to start with the typical
approach and I'll discuss some of the
pain points associated with that
approach then we'll look at the
simplified approach and I'll demonstrate
how you can use the in-memory provider
to really simplify your overall approach
then we'll discuss some of the
limitations and concerns and finally
I'll share with you some learning
resources to help you get up and running
so what is the typical approach so the
typical approach has four steps so the
first one is we need to remove all of
our dependencies on EF so if we have
dependencies on EF then that typically
means that we've got a dependency on
external database and our unit tests
cannot access external resources because
if they do that's going to slow down our
whole test suite and what are we going
to do we're not going to run those tests
they need to be fast so that we can get
that feedback quickly the next thing
we'll do is we'll implement some
abstractions so typically what people
implement is the unit of work and the
repository pattern followed by that
we'll be able to begin writing our tests
but we'll actually have to create test
doubles first so these are our dummy
objects that we can use to test our
system so we'll typically create a dummy
unit of work and a bunch of dummy
repositories so that we can test and
then finally we can write unit tests so
hands up here who is familiar with this
process so everyone and hands up if you
like this process okay so 2% of the room
maybe maybe maybe a little bit more so
but this is a difficult process and for
new developers it's a lot to learn to
get up and running and what I'm seeing
is that time and time again people are
writing very few tests if any so let's
take a look at a simple of
approach where we can do away with some
of this pain so the simplified approach
is in complete contrast to the typical
approach we don't need to remove our
dependencies on EF and we were therefore
why need to implement any abstractions
we can actually use the DB context where
it's required we won't need to create
test doubles in our unit tests we're
going to use the DB context there as
well so we'll just be focusing on one
thing writing unit tests so hands up
again who thinks I'm crazy so you say so
you're wrong I'm simple and I like
simple things so let me show you how we
can do this it's with the e of core in
memory provider it's just a database
provider but it's been built for testing
purposes the big difference is is it's
in memory so it's very fast and it's not
dependent on those external resources so
there's no overhead of those i/o
operations it's lightweight with minimal
dependencies this dependency is energy
framework core so let me show you how
this works
so I've got two demonstrations for you
today and the first demonstration we're
going to test a simple query and this
query is just getting a list of
customers and it does two things it gets
the list of customers without applying
any kind of filtering and it also orders
it by name so we can write two tests for
that but let me show you first how we
can wire in the EF core in-memory
provider so it's quite simple it's a
single package and if I just have a look
at the dependencies here you can see the
dependency is on Microsoft energy
framework caught in memory so don't net
core 2.0 was released on Monday so I've
upgraded this solution to 2.0 and
everything's working great so it's a
very very simple process so the rest of
the dependencies there are just on
testing so let's have a look here so
we're going to write two tests so the
first one is it should return all
customers so we'll start by mooing up
the query so I get custom our query now
you can see that the customer query
requires a DB context and we'll have to
new that up as well
so context equals a new Northwind
context so I'm using a Northland
database that I've built and so we need
to use this constructor and it accepts a
dbcontext options so we'll pass in the
options and we'll have to new that up as
well so with the options we need to use
the dbcontext options builder and we'll
make that of time Northwind context and
we can simply say because we have that
dependency on in memory we can simply
say use in memory database now we also
have to supply a database name this is
new to dotnet core 2.0 we actually
didn't need to do this in the past but
I'll go ahead and just give it a simple
name Northwind and then we can just
return the options okay so now we have
everything we need to begin our test
okay so we'll grab the result and it's
just simply queried I'll execute and
then we can assert actually we're gonna
we're going to ensure that it returns
all customers so we need to seed the
database as well so I have a helper
method to seed the database here and you
can see it down the bottom it just seeds
six customers so we need to assert that
six customers are returned so if we go
assert so equal six and result count
okay with that in place I can do a build
I've set my test to run after build so
that should run and those tests should
pass okay
quite simple now for the second test I'm
just gonna borrow this card and we're
gonna make sure that the customers are
returned in the correct order
[Music]
okay so we can say that alphabetically
Beth Smith should be fast so we can
whack that in there and then we can say
result dot first dot name
how about you no good okay now if I run
those let's see what happens okay so
that fails and the reason that it fails
is even though when Ewing up a new
context with a new in-memory database
for each test it's actually reusing the
same database and you may have guessed
that because I'm using the same database
name now what microsoft recommends that
you do is to name each database after
the test so if I name this one should a
customer by name and the other one his
name should return all customers both of
those tests will pass but this is pretty
ugly this is not the simplest approach
that I could find I found that I'd
actually traded one form of complexity
mocking of my abstractions for another
form of complexity the heavy-handed
management of the context so I created a
new solution let's have a look at this
new solution so we've got a customers
controller and it's a pretty typical Web
API controller but I don't know core 2.0
and you can see that it's got a number
of methods so we're returning customers
we're getting customers by ID and we're
creating updating and deleting customers
so I've written 12 tests for that
controller and you can see at the moment
11 of them are failing and it's because
they're all sharing the same database
but what I've actually done is I've
written these tests the way I'd like to
write my tests they're very simple so
you can see get customers returns
cracked type we've just got our range
act and assert and nothing else aside
from what we actually want to test it's
really clear what's that's doing we've
got another one here and they all follow
this pattern arrange act in a certain
and there's nothing else in there that's
kind of detracting from the actual test
itself so those tests are really as
simple as possible so let's have a look
at how this is constructed and then
we'll look at how we can get this to
work so we've got a constructor here and
a constructor in X unit runs before each
test
so in our constructor we're basically
setting up our context and we're seed in
the database and then right down the
bottom what runs after each test is the
dispose method so that's a pretty good
pattern for what we're trying to achieve
but our problem right now is that
they're all running against the same
database now I found about three
different way
to fix this but what I'm going with
lately is the simplest approach good new
good to string so now we have a unique
data base for each test each each test
run now the other thing that I've been
doing is a little bit of cleanup so I
run context database dot ensure created
and the reason that I do that is because
at the end of each test I'm going to run
context database stop ensure deleted so
I'm not going to have all of these
databases sitting in memory for the test
duration they'll drop out after all the
tests are running but if I've got a
really large test suite that's going to
consume a fair bit of memory so now with
those things in place if I run that all
of these tests are going to pass fingers
crossed there we go so fantastic so now
we have a quite simple approach to unit
testing in these systems but there's one
other thing that that I've implemented
and that is an abstract base class so
instead of having all of this
information in this controller class
word which would then have to be
repeated for other controllers that were
testing I've implemented a Northwind
test base so we can actually delete all
of this and we can delete all of this
and we could just inherit or base our
class on Northwind test base
[Music]
there we go
so now all of that logic associated with
managing the context is in a completely
separate class and our test still wrong
let me show you that class it's going to
be exactly what you expect okay so we
just have a constructor which news up
the context we've got our field level
variables so it can access the context
in our tests and we've got our dispose
methods so that's a really simple
approach you can take it a little bit
further for example you might want to
have a different method for testing your
queries because they can share all of
the same context it can run against the
same context but first testing new
commands or those things that are
writing to the database you definitely
want a separate instance for each test
okay so let's have a talk about some of
the limitations and concerns they're
associated with this approach so the
first thing is in memory is not a
relational database in fact here of
course not relational it can support
relational and no sequel but the fact is
that using this approach your
constraints aren't going to be enforced
you could in fact violate referential
integrity this is this is a small issue
because you need to remember that what
you're testing is not entity framework
or and you're not testing your database
in its behaviors you're testing
something else you're testing something
that depends on entity framework call so
what's important is that in memory
behaves approximately like a real
database and it does a really great job
at that so next up concerns there's
three common concerns that are raised
with this approach the first one is
you're writing an integration tests and
not unit tests and that's not true
to write an integration test I'd
actually need to test against the
provider that I'm going to be using in
production so if I was using sequel
server in production I'd need to test
against the sequel server provider
running integration test against in
memory would only test in memory and
that's not going to production so those
tests have no value so the next one is
lack of isolation you're exercising code
that has dependencies on entity
framework call and that's true I am but
I'm also exercising code that has
dependencies on dotnet core and I'm okay
with that I trust out in their core and
trust entity framework core so I'm happy
with this approach and finally the unit
of work and repository patterns are best
practice and that's true they are best
practice but the fact of the matter is
that energy framework for some time now
has implemented both of those patterns
so the DB context is a unit of work and
the DB set is a repository now I'll stop
there if you are building a big
enterprise system and you want really
clean separation of concerns from your
frameworks it is a good idea to
implement the unit of work and the
repository pattern but the good news is
you can use in memory behind that as
well so instead of mocking your unit of
works and repositories just new them up
with the context in the same way as what
you've seen here today and you'll gain a
lot of these benefits
all right so finally some learning
resources so the first one is the slides
and source code for these demonstrations
so you can find it on bit ly /e of core
testing or on my my github repo at JSON
GT then in October we're running a
dotnet called super bonus we're going to
cover all of this and more everything
you need to get up and running with
dotnet core 2.0 it'll be myself and my
colleague here Brendon Richards
it's a full-day event it's 49 dollars
and we include all meals if you're
interested please do booked in quickly
because they do tend to sell out next if
you enjoy that you might like to check
out the angular superpowers too so the
same deal we're going to show you
everything you need to get up and
running with angular in the enterprise
and that's running on Friday the 17th of
November so in summary today I've shown
you everything you need to do to
implement simplified unit testing for
systems that depend on energy framework
or using the in-memory provider the four
important steps are you don't need to
remove your dependencies on energy
framework or you can in fact use the
dbcontext directly now because of this
you're not going to need to implement
any abstractions and you're not going to
in need to implement test ovals you use
the DB contacts directly in your system
and also in your tests so that it's
going to leave you to focus on just one
thing and that's writing unit tests
thank you
[Applause]